hello everyone and thanks for attending
the first-ever Google genomics webinar
my name is Shree I'm the business head
for Google genomics and today I'll be
walking you through some of the key
features benefits and some cool example
applications of the genomics platform
that we are very actively developing it
is fairly common knowledge now that
sequencing cost has been plummeting much
faster than Moore's Law and the volume
of genomic information is exploding as
you can see in the slide this trend is
not likely to slow down anytime soon
even reasonable projections estimate
that the amount of genomic data will
double every year and will hit one
exabyte within the next five years if
the current trends persist we will hit a
billion genomes by 2025 that's billion
with a B but having all that raw data is
not useful unless you're able to extract
clinical meaning from it we will need to
layer on this raw data a variety of
analytics ranging from data mining novel
algorithms intuitive visualization all
the way to very deep machine learning to
ultimately have patient and healthcare
impact this kind of data quantity
transition has been seen by Google
before we have seen it in search in
video and also email now as scientists
scale up their studies and begin to
query thousands and soon millions of
genomes you will need to have scalable
technologies for manipulating analyzing
and interpreting enormous datasets
without the time or cost of moving that
data from place to place and this is
where Google believes it can help Google
genomics that is built on the Google
cloud platform aims to help the life
science community organize the world
genomic information and make it
accessible and useful and just to give
you some perspective on Google cloud
platform just a part of Google's
infrastructure which supports YouTube
can handle 300 hours of video every
minute
our search which returns you the results
in quarter of a second that search index
is over a hundred petabytes in size now
let's translate that into genomic terms
that is the equivalent of raw data from
six whole genome sequences uploaded to
our servers every minute and we can
index and search the equivalent of a
million whole genome sequences currently
now let's talk about policy and mounting
scientific evidence policy there is
increasing recognition on the importance
of cloud computing for genomic data
analysis so much so that in early March
the NIH updated its genomic data sharing
policy to allow use a public cloud to
store and access genomic data in
parallel there is mounting evidence in
the life science community that
cloud-based genomic data analysis is the
future recent articles in nature
showcased how much cheaper faster and
flexible cloud computing resources were
compared to local data centers Google
cloud platform resources are even cited
as a key public cloud computing resource
that is used increasingly by genomics
researchers Google cloud platform offers
both infrastructure as a service and
platform as a service however we also
build a unique genomics API that powers
many genomic specific features and like
a buffet you can choose whether you want
to use our infrastructure services
platform services or genomic specific
feature set that we have built we group
the key benefits of Google genomics as
store process Explorer and share let's
talk about these one by one store we
enable content-aware storage that is we
know that you are storing 80s DS and C's
and we have separate read and variant
stores that allow a variety of different
functionality all of this data can be
accessed by a web api that is an
implementation of the ga4gh
specifications we store many reference
data sets like thousand genomes platinum
genomes as well as reference sequences
for your analysis I will also talk soon
about a couple of large data sets
that are stored on Google genomics let's
move on to process we allow running of
data processing pipelines to analyze
public or private genomic data stored on
Google genomics in addition we inked a
deal with the Broad Institute recently
to bring the popular gatk pipeline as a
service in a cloud optimized format
moving on to explore we enable tertiary
analysis of genomic data using a variety
of tools for research purposes we enable
usage of Google scale tools like
bigquery that allow real-time analysis
of massive volumes of data moving on to
share we enable sharing of these
datasets painlessly yet securely with
fine-grained access control two-factor
authentication ply increase security at
rest and at transit and security is
paramount to us we sign bas that ensure
our platform supports our customers
HIPAA compliance requirements we also
have a variety of security
certifications and some of the highest
security and encryption standards in the
industry to ensure that your sensitive
data stays safe now let's get a little
bit into the details of how Google
genomics actually works the sequence
data from the sequencer can be stored in
a variety of different file formats such
as fast queue ban or VCFs
on Google Cloud it is then copied from
Google cloud to Google genomics into the
read of variants store at which stage we
know its genetic information the API
calls can then be made to make a variety
of queries or analysis on this data if
you want to do for the tertiary analysis
we also enable specific data cohorts to
be exported to bigquery for further
analysis the interesting thing to note
here is that we enable users of varying
levels of expertise to access and
analyze this data if you are an expert
programmer you can write code if you're
a wet lab scientist you can use a web UI
to write simple SQL type scripts if
you're a by informatics scientists and
your favorite tool is our studio or
ipython notebook you can directly make
API calls from your tool of choice I'd
like to provide a few examples that
illustrate these various benefits we
will start with walking through the
autism
data set and then move on to the
National Cancer Institute's TCGA data
set Autism Speaks is one of the largest
nonprofits focusing on autism related
research as you can see there is
overwhelming evidence now that there is
a genetic basis to the autism spectrum
disorders to understand this genetic
basis Autism Speaks has launched an
ambitious project to sequence 10,000
persons ranging from children with
autism affected as well as unaffected
siblings and parents this entire data
set is going to be made available on
Google genomics for qualified
researchers and when completed will be
over a petabyte in size this dataset
stores genomic data ranging from raw
reads to the variance as well as
phenomics data such as diagnosis result
demographic info family info and a few
other pertinent metadata we already have
about 1700 whole genome sequences and
associated phenomics data for
researchers to start analyzing autism
Speaks
also built a web portal to host this
database to allow interactive querying
of the data set this allows non violent
emissions to easily query and explore
interesting data cohorts now let's talk
about the second valuable data set which
is the National Cancer Institute's TCGA
data set Google genomics is involved in
two of the three winning bids for NCIS
cancer cloud pilot both the open access
TCGA data as well as the controlled
access data requiring dbgap
authorization will be hosted on Google
genomics and just like Autism Speaks is
B is developing a web research portal to
allow users to explore the TCGA data set
and select pertinent cohorts of interest
and open it directly into an eye Python
notebook to continue their analysis
switching gears we will now focus on the
process and explore aspects of our
platform for analysis
we will briefly review Broad's gatk
processing pipeline we will then look at
the open source code examples that we
have made available on github and we
will wrap up with bigquery doing
powerful analysis on genomic data let's
talk about the first example
Google genomics recently announced a
partnership with the Broad Institute
that combines their genomics expertise
with Google's engineering expertise to
help address complex biological
questions a key initial foray in this is
to bring the widely used gatk pipeline
as a service on Google genomics this
enables users to not have to worry about
infrastructure or platform or license
and simply focus on running that
pipeline on their data now let's talk
about bigquery which is a powerful
Google scale tool built originally to
interrogate very large Internet log
files containing millions of entries
turns out this is very well-suited for
querying genomic data for tertiary
analysis needs in this plot bigquery is
being shown to do a count and a plot of
all the variants with a single or two
alleles on the thousand genomes dataset
as you can imagine this is a fairly
heavy-duty calculation and this query
processes a terabyte of data and
provides the result in seven point four
seconds this type of rapid querying was
not previously feasible without using
such powerful google scale tools this
makes research interactive and real-time
resulting in accelerated innovation
finally Google and the research
community are building a growing
repository of open source codes and
tools that are available on github for
researchers they can use it for their
own pipelines or modify it for their
analysis listed here is a subset of some
of these tools which you'll find
valuable and I'll show two of these
examples now for you shown here is an
example of principle coordinate analysis
code that we have made available on
github when we run this PCA analysis on
the entire thousand genome data set and
color code the resulting scatter plot by
population type we get a nice clustering
by ethnicity as expected
here is an example of code created by
Stanford University researchers also
available on github this is used to
perform quality control on genomic data
sets this code specifically plot
heterozygosity rate on the x chromosome
that helps easily identified mislabeled
samples shown in blue dots towards the
top of the graph
we hope to continuously improve this
code set and increase the ecosystem of
valuable code that users can pull from
on our github page like the Autism
Speaks and the TCGA data set we welcome
interest from the community to host
valuable datasets on Google genomics
similarly like gatk we welcome your
analytics pipelines to be hosted and
share on goals in omics as well and that
brings us to the conclusion of this
webinar we hope that you have a good
understanding of Google genomics
platform and how it can really help you
store process explore and share genomic
information for more information please
visit our website listed here thank you
so much
you